can we all just admit it'd be kind of
cool to see John Leguizamo come back as
the violator again so before I get into
the topic that this video is actually
about I just want to say this real
quickly that this is the first video
that I'm recording since my Q&A
celebrating 10,000 subscribers went up
I've had a few videos actually released
since that went up but that was because
I had pre-recorded a couple things which
is something I'm trying to do more of in
general just because it makes my life
easier I'm able to do that but the the
response to that QA was amazing and
phenomenal and you people Rock I am I'm
it makes me really happy of the
subscriber base that I'm cultivating so
no touchy feely good stuff out of the
way let's get to spawn and more
specifically what the latest word is on
the film adaptation well second film
adaptation of the 90s staple so I
suppose a few things for context
I like spawn I actually like spawn a lot
I think those are written those comics
especially the first few years worth
hold up
surprisingly well especially compared to
a lot of other stuff from the 90s I
really like the spawn animated series
the spawn film it's kind of fun I mean I
called out John Leguizamo in the intro
for a reason he's the best thing about
it but it's it's pretty dumb but todd
mcfarlane the original creator or spawn
has been trying to get a second film
made for decades now
now despite that he's always kind of
talked up a similar general vibe which
is he want to do something much more as
a horror movie now way back you know
years ago he was saying it could still
be a follow up to the first one that
doesn't really seem to be the case too
much anymore and the thing is he has
been talking about this for so long it's
the sort of thing that you know he would
bring up intermittently and I just kind
of go oh okay he's still talking about
that and assumed it would never happen
well a month or two back he actually
paired with bloom house studios and they
have set a 10 million dollar budget for
him to do a new spawn movie and then he
said something pretty recently which I
found intriguing and what he said is he
basically gonna treat spawn like the
shark in Jaws he's going to you know
drive the plot he's going to be you know
ever-present he's gonna be vital he's
not gonna speak and it's going to focus
much more on well he didn't say
specifically he made the comparison that
in Jaws you focus on the sheriff sheriff
Brody I hope people have seen jaws see
jaws it's an amazing movie um but anyway
he makes that comparison although he
does not explicitly say who the film
would center around so I'm gonna
speculate a little bit about that and
sort of talk about this as a general
premise now if this was the only
adaptation of spawn we had ever gotten I
would probably be a little bit annoyed
by this because it feels like it's not
exploring a lot of what could be done
with spawn but here's what I've always
liked about the various adaptations of
spawn is that they are all different
from each other and we've gotten a very
action-heavy one with the movie we got
something pretty true to the original
comics with the animate with a spawn
animated series so since I have that I'm
much more open to a new interpretation
of spawn on the big screen that is
decidedly different and actually Todd
McFarlane he's a bit of an odd character
he's he's pulled some really douchey
things in his day but he's also somebody
who I have a surprising amount of
respect for especially on the artistic
front that's not me saying he has the
world's greatest artistic integrity but
I like his perception of a lot of things
and one thing I remember him saying a
long time ago like right around when the
spawn animated series and the then the
movie had come out and since they were
such different takes he said you know if
I'm going to be involved in adapting
this story why would I want to do the
same story again I want to do it
differently every time otherwise where's
the fun and I've always admired that
approach so certainly doing a more
horror tinged spawn himself as more of a
creeping malevolent force certainly fits
with doing it as a different
interpretation and normally my gut
instinct would be ten million dollars
even if you're like keeping him in the
shadows that seems really tight but I'm
at
really fairly heartened by the fact that
he's partnered with bloom house studios
now bloom house studios if you don't
know that name they have been making a
pretty solid name for themselves
backing small budget but well produced
horror films they were the studio behind
split they were the studio that backed
to get out so the the the guy Steven
bloom has a really good eye for for what
has potential and this studio seems to
have a really good notion of where to
allocate the assets of a tight budget so
that they do produce things for you know
ten twelve million dollar range which is
really cheap by today's moviemaking
standards but make something that does
not look cheap because they're really
smart about where the money gets spent
you don't try and make something that
normally would take a hundred million
dollars on a ten million dollar budget
it just looks cheap you have to plan
from the ground up for the budget you
have which is another thing that todd
mcfarlane has talked about he talked
about you know looking into locations
really carefully to maximize the amount
of money because most of Spawn even
though it's it's a story set in
manhattan it takes place in the alleys
you can shoot an alley anywhere you can
build an alley set for much cheaper then
it will cost you to film on location in
New York and I just like where his
headspace is that in terms of talking
about things like you know if I save a
hundred thousand dollars on a location
that's a hundred thousand dollars that
can go towards an effect that's a
hundred thousand dollars that can go
towards a really good stunt gag and I
just I love the way this is being
approached in terms of making the best
possible ten million dollar spawn movie
that could possibly be made if there's a
hitch to this it will primarily be the
fact that Todd McFarlane is he's writing
it which I'm fine with but he's also
supposed to direct and he hasn't
directed before he's contributed usually
animation related stuff to say music
videos and whatnot but he hasn't he
hasn't really directed live-action
before so that makes me nervous
that being said I don't know how
hands-on of a producer Steven Blum is
but you know Jordan Peele also hadn't
made a movie before he did get out
I think what Jordan Peele had done
probably lent him to being able to
direct the movie a little bit more than
what Todd McFarlane has done but it
being his first movie and knowing that
it's a tightly controlled budget
scenario actually gives me a little more
confidence than say the fact that Simon
Kinberg is directing his very first film
and it's x-men Dark Phoenix you don't
give a brand-new director that much
money because they don't know what to do
with it so that's a that's a slight
concern but it's not as big a concern as
it would be if this was a bigger
production than it supposedly is now I
said was gonna speculate a little bit so
the obvious assumption if Todd McFarlane
is making the comparison of the main
character of Jaws being Sheriff Brodie
would be to assume that the main
character or possibly characters of
spawn or at least the POV characters
would be Sam and twitch now that is
speculation man I hope it's true though
I love salmon twitch they are awesome
characters they play well off each other
they are a wonderful just embracing but
also slight spin on it pretty tried and
true you know cop duo they don't really
break the mold in a lot of ways but they
just are a great distillation of that
kind of buddy cop partnering situation
my main question about all of this going
in is if you're comparing spawn to the
shark that would effectively also make
him the villain of the piece and I'm not
entirely sure what I think about that I
mean I'm fine with like people the cops
are the people in the alley whatever
being afraid of him that works totally
fine but if he is effectively the
villain then I'm I question a little bit
more and in terms of who else could be
the villain if they're keeping to a ten
million dollar budget there aren't a ton
of options because most of spawns really
iconic villains are expensive to realize
that I mean the violator being a big one
you could do the clown again but you
know I think John Leguizamo did honestly
do it as good as it was gonna be done in
live-action if he's not gonna transform
into the violator
you know why is he here other ones like
anti spawn and and
tremor and you know all these these are
difficult to realize visually on any
budget especially on a 10 million dollar
budget so I really do wonder what what I
wonder is if it'll be something a little
bit along the lines of the second season
of the spon animated series which
brought things really down to the street
level and it dealt with way less
fantastical stuff and it had ordinary
scummy crying people messing around in
the alley I suppose you could bring in
Tony twists you know as a mob boss who's
getting wrapped up and tangled in all
this all day yeah they may have to
change that name because todd mcfarlane
got sued over that because he borrowed
the nickname of a hockey player without
permission so if we get an equivalent to
the character from the comic of Tony
twist they might not be allowed to call
him that at least not without cutting a
check but overall the more I find out
about this the more intrigued I just get
I really want to see what gets made out
of this and I mean like I said I think a
lot of people just lump all of early
Image Comics together you know uh
Youngblood and cyber force and Brigade
and spawn it's all crap it's not there's
actually some good stuff from back in
the day with image I think spawn
probably holds up the best of I'd say
everything except the max which is
really on its own little pedestal so I'm
curious I'm tentatively excited even
which is weird for me especially for
something this early in production I'm
usually not that optimistic I'm not to
say that I expect things to suck but I
tend to have a very critical eye my
brain zeroes in on the way something can
go wrong as opposed to the way something
could go right it's just kind of what
happens but I'm feeling oddly I don't
want to say positive but I definitely I
want to find out more because so far the
more I find out the more I'm like okay
okay so those are my thoughts on the
news we have so far about a new spawn
movie what are your thoughts about any
of this whatever they are drop something
down in the comments
let's talk about it do all the stuff
like and subscribe and I'm on Twitter
I've got an email I've got
Podcast links for all the stuff is down
below so until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]